joining us from our friends at NBC and
from football night in America and his
football morning in America Monday
column that can be seen every single
week on the old internet he's our friend
Peter King hello Peter hey how you doing
well I'm trying to figure out heads or
tails if there's gonna be a cba by the
end of the combine what do you think
Peter probably my gut feeling is no you
know I mean this is a obviously
multifaceted story and situation but you
know I always get a kick out of people
who read a headline or do some whatever
some discovery about some big story and
then all of a sudden say no this thinks
we're not doing it I mean you've had you
know at least as far as players ago
you've had a designated group of players
negotiating a you know a new CBA for ten
months with a group of owners and to me
I think probably the more logical
reaction after something like this comes
out is well have I'll have an opinion
when I see the whole thing but I always
sort of chuckle at all people who say
well we're not going to take this deal
it stinks and it may stink but wouldn't
you want to find out about it first
before you said that and that I think
was basically the knee-jerk reaction by
a lot of people last night so you know
right now again things can change
certainly even by the end of this
conversation but right now the reporting
is that the the Executive Committee of
The Players Association in advancing it
to the 32 player reps recommended to
vote against the six to five and as our
colleague Judy Batista of NFL Media
Group points out the twist in this is
that some of the members of the
executive committee were in the room to
negotiate this
so maybe they were part of the five that
said yes to this I mean what what uh
what do you make of and all of this
Peter well I think all along there have
been a group of a cadre of players who
said we do not want more than 16 games
in the regular season schedule and
rightfully so you know this is a time
rich where every every person who
watches or pays any attention in the NFL
understands that you know understands
that you know this is a very dangerous
game that does not get less dangerous
when you add 60 more snaps or 65 more
snaps that starting players would have
to play during the course of the year I
think that far in a way it was the
biggest mistake about this new deal and
then I do you know Richard Sherman spoke
out against it quite eloquently and I
thought at the Super Bowl and he
obviously is on that executive committee
I do think there are some other issues
with this you know I can't imagine that
anybody who makes a lot of money when
you tell him that hey you make 1.5
million dollars a week during the season
but for this 17th game you'll make
250,000 dollars that when I first saw
that I said that just doesn't figure now
I believe that the Union probably said
look this is it's more important for a
real rank-and-file this is not going to
affect that many players so you know we
would rather see players in them in the
middle part of the curve compensated
significantly for that 17th game however
there are just so many players that are
going to be affected by that I can't
imagine that going over well and then I
think the other part of it that players
just almost naturally wouldn't like is
that this is being done basically 13
months before or 14 months before the
CBA will expire and even though there
are benefits to do
now I think a lot of players would say
what's the rush let's take it to the end
and let's see what happens I do think
though rich one of the other parts of
this is that you know NFL players just
have never had the stomach for a strike
and that's at the end of the day that is
what is probably going to doom any
revolutionary type of change in a
contract with the owners Peter King of
NBC Sports and of course the Peter King
podcast right here on the Rich Eisen
show ok I'll ask you the same question I
asked our buddy Adam Schefter the other
day is there anything to that Joe burrow
doesn't want to play for the Cincinnati
Bengals rumor that keeps on getting
bigger and stronger not that I know of
rich I don't I don't know anything about
it other than you know the Joe borough
camp has been extremely quiet you know
his his agents have been quiet
everybody's been quiet about it and
really all he has to do is come out and
say whoever grabs when y'all played for
him it feels like he's almost said that
but he really hasn't said that in so
many words and that's all that has to
happen without saying that it's logical
that speculation would run rampant it
doesn't strike me that he would pull an
Eli Manning or a John Elway but having
said that I don't know I have zero
inside information on rich yeah I mean
and it was announced just this morning
he will be for those scoring at home he
will be on Tuesday at 9 a.m. Eastern
time at podium number three for
everybody to talk to and I guess he's
got a at some point someone's just gonna
put the question point blank to him or
do you want to play for the Bengals or
not and I imagine that is going to be
question number one for him because a
lot of the I have leverage or if they
take me they take me calm comments is
what's been adding more and more you
know gasoline on this rumor right yeah
again you know it's sort of hard for me
to think that he will take a militant
stance all that is though as a guess
he seems like a guy who wants to play
football and will play as hard as no
matter where he is but again we'll see I
guess we'll start to find that out on
Tuesday we've given a half of the poll
question choices Christopher to our
guest Peter King right here ask him our
poll question that's up on at Rich Eisen
show on our Twitter feed yeah Peter
what's the biggest NFL offseason
storyline Tom Brady's future job reverse
the Bengals to his health or the 17 game
expansion and the bigger playoffs Brady
nothing is even close for second place
and that one as far as I'm concerned
especially if Brady leaves just imagine
if Tom Brady is in a different uniform
next year wherever it is Tennessee here
the chargers or Vegas just it would be
revolutionary for this league guy who
plays one place for 1/5 of the history
of the National Football League and then
tries to win it again and resuscitate
his career somewhere else that I don't
think there can be anything bigger than
that at least I wouldn't think what's
your best guess is were sitting here
right now we're less than a month now
until the new league year window
negotiating window if you will opens up
what he got for me on that Peter well I
think this is this is probably going to
be a situation where he very likely will
have a chance to make more money
elsewhere let's say the Raiders you know
for example I I just I just think that
at some point Jon Gruden is going to try
to grab him by the scruff of the neck
and say please please whatever it takes
I'll I want you but I said yeah I wrote
the other day that that I thought that
the most logical thing without I mean
this is a this is a I would call it a
mild prediction is that
returns to New England because I other
than the time I spent with him right
after his last game I have not spoken to
him and I think this is all going to be
dependent on what Bill teletrac wants I
think there are a lot of logical things
logic tells me that the Chargers are
going to be more of a long-term play in
other words draft Justin Herbert play
Tyrod Taylor this year develop the young
quarterback and don't take the easy way
to selling luxury suites in year one at
the new stadium I think that it's most
logical if I were John Robinson I'd
certainly take the long play and sign
Ryan Tannehill for a long time
rich I don't think anybody even thinks
about this Ryan Tannehill played 15
games this year and he had the best
passer rating by a quarterback in the
NFL since 2013 and you know this is it's
not like he played three or four games
he played 15 so what's what's not to
want to re-sign him for and then I think
the other usual suspects I think if I
had to put five bucks down in Vegas
right now no pun intended
Bruton provided with five bucks down I'd
say Philip Rivers to Indianapolis it's
too logical a fit with Frank Reich and
and and so much of that offense him
knowing you know Nick Syriana the
offensive coordinator was there for
three years in San Diego with them and
then Teddy Bridgewater in Tampa those
would be my initial guesses here about
Hans out so then where does Jameis go
Peter I think he's gonna have to go some
I doubt sincerely go somewhere in
somebody handsome a starting job the
place that I think it would be so
intriguing I would love to see Jameis
Winston go to Pittsburgh and backup
Roethlisberger
for this year and then maybe have the
job in 2021 and beyond I mean how great
would it be I think I think he's played
right now for Dirk cutter Bruce Arians
Byron Leftwich and he's played for a
bunch of offensive guys who have tried
to fix everything around him maybe just
need some tough love from from a Mike
Tomlin you know I don't know but
obviously the coaching he's gotten so
far has not cut down his his kryptonite
which is the turnovers and something's
got to be done about that I think and
then you mentioned Vegas you know I just
is it just because everybody knows
Gruden and Gruden did love Jameis too or
the fact that Gruden loves veteran
quarterbacks or we think or we think
that aegis is never happy with the
quarterback that he has he just likes
collecting him I mean is that why that
we're talking about that he you know Jon
Gruden his favorite quarterback is
always the one he doesn't ask and you
know so I I think Vegas is definitely in
play effort for anybody you know for
Brady for Jameis whoever I you know I
don't know who Jon Gruden loves out
there right now I do know that that it
would have been very easy for the
Raiders at some point late in the season
or this offseason to say stop putting
all these quarterbacks in Vegas Derek
Carr is our guy
we're not going to be looking at any
other quarterbacks in the offseason they
haven't said that so that leads to blue
that leads you to question that's the
same kind of questions that everybody is
wondering about with Joe pearl a few
minutes I have left with you Peter King
what about cam is what's going on with
him what do you think this I thought it
was pretty telling last week when you
know when the owner of the Panthers
basically said talk to me when he's
healthy is he healthy we don't know or
and I'm pair of
raising but I said something like that I
mean you know enough about Cam Newton's
physical condition to know what kind of
physical shape he's in right now and how
his shoulder is how can you not really
and so that said to me like they've
already mentally started thinking about
life after camp now that's just me
having covered the league for a long
time that might not be what David Tepper
is thinking but it sure sounded like
that's what he's thinking but one thing
you know about temper and I mentioned
Phillip Rivers to Indianapolis Teddy
Bridgewater to Tampa David Tepper proved
with the mat rule negotiations or or or
or I don't even call it a negotiation I
call it handing him a lottery ticket and
in making him you know basically the
highest-paid first-year head coach ever
in the NFL you know if you if you're
going to give that rule eight point
eight million a year when he has been in
the NFL for one year as an assistant
offensive line coach
well that just says to me that if David
Tepper really wants something if he
really wants Phillip Rivers he'll out I
don't know that he'll get him right but
he will outbid anybody else who wants
Phillip Rivers same thing with Teddy
Bridgewater's so that's the thing right
now that we don't know they've been a
pretty tight ship right now in Carolina
so you don't really hear a lot of good
or reliable rumors out of there but to
me if David Tepper wants one of these
guys on the market he'll he'll be able
to go get him or has given his coach so
much security and with Olson now in
Seattle and Lukey CLE gone yeah and and
maybe you're right maybe they're maybe
they're gonna start from scratch which
is why Justin Herbert and and and just
and play at the patient play is play the
long game
well Daniel Jeremiah said in terms of
the long game he was here yesterday
what about tanking for Trevor Trevor
Oren's lurks sir down the horizon I mean
yeah I mean look at everybody said the
exact same thing a year ago about the
Dolphins then the Dolphins dumped three
of their top they already were a crappy
team they've dumped three of their top
ten players yeah and then they they won
more games after Halloween than the New
England Patriots so I don't understand
how anybody could logically say hey
let's try to get the first pick next
year there's a matter of playing the
games and unless you're going to fix the
games it's pretty hard to say in a year
where you could get Justin Herbert hey
wait a second let's try to go one in 15
next year so we can be sure we get
Trevor lines how do you know you're
going one in 15 right how do you know
somebody else isn't going one in 15 or
you know so that's a pretty dangerous
game to play in my opinion Peter I'll
see you at the combine thanks for the
call we'll see an Indy all right good
luck thank you thanks brother right back
at you that's Peter King for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 under red TV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app